je regarde on sait jamais si bon nous
allons
pouvoir démarrer donc mes chers
collègues alors nous sommes aujourd'hui
le 25 janvier et c'est la première fois
cette année que nous fêtons le enfin
nous fêtons nous célébrons nous je sais
pas quoi le 25 janvier c'est la journée
aujourd'hui contre le sexisme euh donc
voilà c'est important et ça tombe bien
ça tombe sur une journée de délégation
au droits des femmes une journée qui
sera chargé puisque beaucoup de
d'associations ont décidé de célébrer
cette journée de lutte contre le sexisme
et après le rapport que le HCE vient de
sortir sur l'état du sexisme en France
dont on voit que ce n'est pas du tout un
problème de génération comme on
l'espérait en se disant que les jeunes
générations seraient moins touché que
les plus
anciennes et bien ça n'est pas du tout
le cas les jeunes ne sont pas moins
sexiste que leurs
aînés bien au contraire et donc il nous
reste encore un gros travail à mener sur
le sujet mais revenons donc à notre
sujet qui a effectivement été salué ce
matin sur France interre je vois
Laurence Rossignol qui arrive et qui
nous l'a signalé mais nous étions
plusieurs derrière la radio à avoir
entendu à roseencherre citer les travaux
du Sénat effectivement le Sénat peut
être tout à fait à la page y compris en
matière de féminisme donc je reprends
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons ce
matin nos travaux sur les familles
monoparental j'ai à mes côté les deux
rapporteurs de notre mission flash
colombe brossell et Béatrice goselin et
nous aitionnons ce matin le Haut Conseil
de la famille de l'enfance et de l'âge
nous accueillons Hélène Périvier
présidente du conseil de la famille du
hcfea et voilà et nous avions déjà eu
l'occasion d'auditionner des
représentants du hcfea l'année dernière
dans le cadre de nos travaux sur la
parentalité dans les
outremes mené en commun avec la
délégation sénatoriale aux
outremes leur expertise nous avait
éclairé sur les spécificités des
structures familiales dans les outremers
et avait déjà à l'époque mis l'accent
sur le sujet des familles
monoparentales en effet si en France
hexagonale 25 % des familles avec enfant
sont des familles monoparentales cette
proportion atteint 50 % aux Antilles et
en
Guyane il s'agit en outre d'une
monoparentalité spécifique qui ne fait
généralement pas suite à une séparation
mais commence dès la naissance 60 % des
naissances n'étant pas reconnu par le
père contre eux seulement 10 % en France
hexagonale nous avons décidé de
poursuivre cette année nos travaux
autour des familles monoparentales dans
une approche plus globale
si les constats autour des
problématiques rencontrées par les
familles monoparentales sont désormais
connues nous nous intéressons au
solutions et aux préconisations pour
mieux soutenir et accompagner ses
familles un axe central est celui de la
lutte contre la pauvreté la précarité et
le mallogement en effet 41 % des enfants
de famillees monoparentales vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté contre 16 % des
enfants dont les parents vivent en
couple
les prestations versées aux familles
monoparentales vous semblent-elles à la
hauteur du coût de l'enfant et du surcou
lié à la
monoparentalité qui s'explique par
l'absence d'économie d'échelle notamment
en matière de logement des évolution du
régime des allocations vous
semble-t-elle nécessaire le sujet de la
déconjugalisation de l'allocation de
soutien familial ASF a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises par de précédents
intervenants qu'en pensez c'est vous
nous nous intéressons également au sujet
des pensions alimentaires leur montant
moyen n'est que de 170 € par mois et
elles ne sont pas toujours versées de
manière régulière en dépit de la mise en
place de l'agence de recouvrement et
d'intermédiation des pensions
alimentaires la Ripa avez-vous des
recommandations dans ce domaine et
particulièrement dans le calcul de ces
pensions puisque certaines associations
nous ont dit le coût d'un enfant 750 €
par mois une pension alimentaire d'une
moyenne de 170 € c'est-à-dire la le
quart seulement de ce que peut coûter un
enfant ce qui voudrait dire que les
3/4art repose sur le parent qui garde
l'enfant donc est-ce logique plus
globalement vous nous ferez part de vos
préconisations pour mieux accompagner
les familles monoparentales et pour
faciliter leur accès à l'emploi au
logement au service public aux solutions
de
garde soutenez-vous par exemple la
création d'un statut spécifique
sous quelle forme juridique et avec
quels avantages le cas échéant je laisse
je vous laisse sans plus tarder la
parole madame Hélène
Périvier merci beaucoup madame merci
beaucoup à toute la délégation de nous
recevoir pour cette audition et ce sujet
dont nous nous réjouissons qu'il soit à
nouveau à l'agenda des politiques
publiques il y a effectivement beaucoup
à faire en la matière je voudrais juste
ajouter que donc je suis président du
conseil de la famille du hcfa je suis
aussi économiste à l'OFCE et c'est ces
deux casquettes que je vais mobiliser
pour répondre au mieux à vos questions
euh puisque c'est un sujet qui est
largement investi par les sciences
sociales depuis longtemps et donc il me
semble assez important aussi de de faire
appel à ces travaux pour mieux
comprendre à la fois la situation
socio-économique des mères isolées parce
que le plus souvent on va revenir dessus
ce sont des femmes qui ont la charge euh
la garde principale des enfants et donc
il y a des enjeux très importants en
mati matière d'égalité des sexes
évidemment en matière d'égalité sociale
en matière d'égalité des enfants face à
leur conditions de vie donc c'est un
enjeu qui est au croisement de multiples
questionnements que que que nous devons
avoir dans dans une société comme la
France qui ne peut pas se se contenter
de voir des des familles dans des
situations de grande précarité alors je
vais commencer un peu par prendre un peu
de façon euh logique les questions
telles que vous me les Avaz posé je
seraai plus ou moins précise selon ces
questions je pense qu'il y a d'autres
personnes qui seront plus à même à
répondre à certaines d'entre elles donc
je vais me concentrer sur les questions
sur lesquelles je je pense pouvoir vous
apporter des éclairages qui guideront
vos travaux sur la question du cou de
l'enfant je voudrais juste la la
première question que vous souvlez est
une question très importante parce que
la question du coût de l'enfant n'est
pas une question simple mesurer le coût
de l'enfant c'est pas du tout quelque
chose de Trivial on peut juste se
contenter de regarder les dépenses qui
sont nécessaires pour pour élever un
enfant les dépenses matérielles ça c'est
évidemment le le périmètre le plus
strict mais évidemment derrière le coût
de l'enfant il y a aussi par exemple le
renoncement à une carrière la prise d'un
d'un la prise d'un temps
partiel le plus souvent encore une fois
des des mères qui implique un coût
important et je reviendrai dessus donc
cette question du coût de l'enfant elle
doit être prise dans son entièreté parce
qu'elle crée aussi des situations de
grande précarité pour certaines familles
alors
de ce point de vue-là ce que nous ce que
nous savons d'abord c'est que au moment
de la séparation des couples il y a une
baisse de niveau de vie pour les deux
nouveaux
foyers à la fois le parent dit gardien
c'est-à-dire le parent qui va avoir la
garde principale de l'enfant et le
parent dit non gardien c'est-à-dire
celui qui n'aura pas la garde principale
de l'enfant et qui du coup sera amené à
verser ce qu'on appelle une c3e
c'est-à-dire une pension alimentaire au
titre de ses devoirs de contribuer à
l'éducation de ses enfants euh donc donc
cette perte de niveau de vie elle est
elle est temporaire et assez faible pour
le parents non gardien qui sont le plus
souvent les hommes elle est par contre
très importante hein il y a un travail
de Linc qui a été fait par garbintis
solaz et Bonet qui montre que c'est à
peu près 19 % de perte de niveau de vie
des mères au moment de la séparation
c'est en tenant compte à la fois des
transferts publics et des transferts
privés c'est donc une fois que les
pensions alimentaires ont été versées
lorsqu'elles le sont et une fois que le
système social fiscal est venu compenser
euh un certain nombre de de de points
pour soutenir ces familles donc une
perte de niveau de vie substantiel qui
affecte évidemment les mères et leurs
enfants euh qui est dû en partie et je
le disais tout à l'heure à la le retrait
partiel ou total d'activité ou la
moindre carrière qu'ont pu avoir les
femmes lorsqu'elles ont des enfants je
ne développe pas ce point c'est
extrêmement bien documenté notamment
chez les économistes on a maintenant ce
terme qui s'appelle le child penalty qui
est bien identifié c'est-à-dire la
pénalité au sens économique euh qui est
lié à l'arrivée d'un enfant qui est très
fort pour les femmes et qui se constate
dans tous les pays pas seulement en
France alors que les revenus économiques
des hommes reste stable après la
naissance d'un enfant donc on voit que
il y a derrière euh cette séparation des
enjeux en termes de niveau de vie très
important je voudrais creuser maintenant
la notion de niveau de vie parce que
c'est une question que vous soulevez qui
est très importante euh le niveau de vie
c'est c'est un c'est une métrique qui
nous permet de comparer euh les
conditions de vie de ménages de taille
différentes parce qu'il ne suffit pas de
prendre en compte le revenu bien
évidemment il faut prendre en compte la
taille de du ménage bien évidemment une
personne qui vit seule avec 1000 € par
mois n'a pas le même niveau de vie
qu'une mère isolée qui vit avec 1000 €
par mois et son enfant alors comment
maintenant pouvoir comparer le niveau de
vie de ces deux ménages pour cela on
utilise une métrique qui s'appelle les
cieles
d'équivalence on va donc attribuer une
part pour le premier une unité pour le
premier adulte et puis 05 pour le second
adulte et 0,3 pour des enfants de moins
de 14 ans dans le cas que je donnais ce
qui implique que pour avoir le même
niveau de vie une mère isolée avec un
enfant de moins de 14 ans doit disposer
d'un revenu de 1300 € mensuel par
rapport à la personne seule cette
métrique est évidemment très importante
elle nous permet de mesurer les
inégalités les taux de pauvreté donc
c'est quelque chose qui est très ancré à
la fois dans les diagnostics que nous
pouvons porter sur nos sociétés mais
aussi sur les politiques publiques que
nous sommes amenés à proposer pour
répondre à ces défis or euh cette
échelle d'équivalence et c'est
aujourd'hui maintenant bien documenté
sous-estime on sur-estime le niveau de
vie des des mères isolées donc
sous-estime leur précarité leur pauvreté
pourquoi parce que on va considérer que
les les économies d'échelle sont
surestimées pour une mère qui vit avec
son enfant en particulier s'agissant du
logement que vous mentionnez dans vos
questions il est bien évident que si
vous comparez un couple et une mère avec
son enfant le couple n'a besoin que
d'une chambre une mère avec son enfant a
priori aurait besoin de deux et donc on
ne peut pas considérer que les économies
échelles sont de même ampleur donc nos
échelles d'équivalence je ne rentre pas
dans les détails si vous êtes intéressé
il y a deux travaux récents donc un
travail que j'ai mené avec Henry Martin
et puis un travail très récent et très
intéressant de l'adresse publiée en 2023
que je vous invite à consulter qui
montre bien les écueils que nous avons
avec ce avec cette cet outil qu'il
convient de repenser pour mieux prendre
en compte les échells d'équivalence
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça pard
c'est juste pour vous dire que nous les
avons auditionnés effectivement bah
voilà parfait euh donc une fois qu'on a
dit ça le taux de pauvreté des des mères
enfin des parents isolés est de bien
plus important que toutes les autres
configurations familiales puisqu'il est
de l'ordre de 35 % et je le rappelle il
est sous-estimé donc on voit bien que là
l'enjeu est extrêmement important en
matière de politique publique eu
de une fois qu'on a dit ça on voit bien
qu'il y a deux façons de soutenir le
niveau de vie des des foyers
monoparentaux d'une part je l'ai dit des
transferts privés d'autre part des
transferts publics euh les transferts
privés on va en parler c'est
essentiellement la ces trois œs
c'est-à-dire la contribution à
l'éducation et l'entretien des enfant
qu'on appelle communément la pension
alimentaire qui doit être versé par le
parent non gardien au parents gardien et
puis il y a du fait de ces difficultés
tout à fait spécifiques que rencontrent
ces familles un certain nombre de de
politiques publiques qui viennent
soutenir le niveau de vie des familles
par plusieurs biais je voudrais avant de
rentrer sur la question de la pension
peut-être mettre un peu l'accent sur les
politiques
publiques pour vous dire quand même que
le système socio-iscal prend bien en
compte enfin insuffisamment certes mais
il y a quand même un certain nombre de
dispositifs assez nombreux he qui
tiennent compte de cette situation
spécifique de monoparentalité pas si
spécifique que ça d'ailleurs comme vous
l'avez dit ça représente presque un
quart des familles avec enfants donc on
est on est sur quand
même une configuration qui est
extrêmement importante une configuration
familiale qui est extrêmement
importante néanmoins c'est vrai que
notre système socioiscal a été pensé
dans son origine hein donc si on prend
l'origine c'est-à-dire la sortie de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale pour être un un
système qui qui dans lequel les
configurations familiales sont des
personnes qui se marient qui restent
mariés qui ne divorc pas qui ont des
enfants or aujourd'hui on le sait il y a
une multiplicité de formes de famille le
conseil de la famille avait d'ailleurs
fait un panorama de ces différentes
configurations familiales les personnes
ne se marient pas nécessairement lorsque
elles se mari elles peuvent se séparer
euh on peut avoir des enfants hors
mariage dans le mariage il y a des
recompositions familiales donc il y a en
fait un parcours de vie qui est assez
complexe et même si le système
sociofiscal s'est en partie adapté il
reste encore aujourd'hui face à ce défi
qui est de répondre à ces multiplicités
de besoins qui sont par ailleurs pas
stables hein j'attire votre attention
sur le fait qu'on n'est pas forcément
mère isolé toute sa vie même si la
remise en couple est beaucoup plus
difficile pour les femmes qu'elle ne
l'ai euh pour les hommes qui ne sont pas
euh qui n'ont pas la charge principale
de leur enfant donc là il y a vraiment
un défi de coller au mieux à la réalité
au niveau de vie des gens et en même
temps voilà d'avoir des politiques
publiques qui soient compréhensibles et
manipulables ce qui est un défi loin
d'être facile à
relever donc dans ce dans ces
dispositifs je viens aujourd'hui si on
regarde la façon dont les la situation
spécifique des familles monoparentales
est prise en compte elle est prise par
des dispositions fiscales par exemple la
demi-part accordé pour isolement par des
prestations dédiées on reviendra dessus
laallocation de soutien familial par des
majorations de plafond hein parce que ça
je rentrerai pas trop dans cette dans ce
détail là mais bien évidemment les
prestations sous conditions de
ressources utilisent des plafonds pour
savoir pour mesurer l'éligibilité des
personnes et ces plafonds peuvent être
majorés selon dans certaines situations
c'est le cas de la prime de naissance de
la location de base de la page du CMG du
RSA de la prime d'activité enfin il y a
tout un ensemble de dispositifs dans
lequel les les les plafonds sont majorés
quand il y a isolement les montants
aussi peuvent l'être également he c'est
le cas du RSA de la prime d'activité du
CMG et puis par exemple s'agissant de
l'allocation de congé parental prépare
il y a une majoration de durée donc
voilà vous voyez qu'il y a quand même un
certain nombre d'éléments qui essae de
prendre en compte cette situation
spécifique malgré ces transferts publics
qui soutiennent et je tiens quand même à
le dire qui soutiennent quand même
beaucoup la situation socio-économique
des familles monoparentales il y a quand
même cette baisse de niveau de vie que
j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure qui reste
qui reste importante donc comment faire
pour essayer de soutenir davantage les
familles monoparentales alors peut-être
que j'oublierai des éléments mais on
reviendra dans la dans la discussion euh
ce dispositif je je vais peut-être faire
un focus sur l'allocation de soutien
familial d'abord et puis ensuite on
reviendra sur la façon dont ça ça se ça
s'articule avec la pension alimentaire
mais vous le voyez dans le panorama que
j'ai dressé c'est une petite partie de
l'ensemble des questions qui se posent
he pour soutenir les familles
monoparentales
euh alors
euh peut-être juste un point et je
développerai pas mais peut-être que vous
allez les auditionner il y a quand même
beaucoup de travaux en sociologie et en
droit sur le traitement judiciaire des
séparations conjugales je pense
notamment aux travaux d'Émilie bilan
Curinier sibyil golac Hélen Steinmetz
notamment qui ont publié très récemment
un ouvrage collectif euh qui utilise des
données de de jugement euh c'est une
source très importante parce que on n'a
pas forcément toutes les ressources
statistiques qui nous permettent de vous
donner une vision parfaitement claire
euh des différentes situations euh de
séparation euh que ce soit en terme de
recours aux prestations ou en terme de
montant de ces trois œufs enfin tout ça
est assez complexe donc je je vais pas
rentrer sur ces questions-là mais je
vous invite à regarder ces travaux-là
que je pourrais vous donner les les
références exact qui qui peuvent vous
être extrêmement utiles euh sur le sujet
que vous traitez
euh
donc s'agissant du du de l'allocation de
soutien
familial derrière cette prestation en
fait il y a trois prestations
différentes et c'est important de de le
garder en tête parce que peut-être qu'il
faudrait distinguer ces trois ces trois
dispositifs qui n'ont pas le même le
même objectif la location de soutien
familial elle peut-être dite non
recouvrable lorsqu'elle est donnée et
c'est d'ailleurs le le le poids le plus
important hein dans ces dans cette
allocation c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
le cas le plus important lorsque que
soit il n'y a pas de parents dans le cas
de d'enfant orphelin soit lorsque
l'enfant n'a qu'un seul parent qui l'a
reconnu vous citiez ce caslà dans votre
propos introductif soit lorsque l'un des
parents est jugé hors d'état pour
prendre en charge une partie de
l'entretien de son enfant dans ces
cas-là on verse la SF à ce titre là elle
est dite non recouvrable parce que il y
aura pas de de chose à il y aura pas de
parents qui pourront qui pourra une finé
prendre cette charge qui et il s'agit
donc de soutenir lorsque il est là le
parent qui existe pour pouvoir l'aider à
assumer l'éducation de son enfant dans
de bonnes conditions le deuxième
dispositif c'est ce qu'on appelle l'ASF
complémentaire l'ASF complémentaire elle
vise à compléter les pensions
alimentaires qui sont fixées par le juge
et qui sont jugées insuffisantes ou qui
sont insuffisantes parce que parfois
c'est c'est c'est dû au fait que les
ressources du parent non-gardien ne sont
pas suffisante pour pouvoir lui demander
une pension alimentaire à la hauteur des
besoins de l'enfant euh c'est plus
compliqué ça encore une fois je
développe pas mais mes collègues
juristes et et sociologues ont fait un
travail extrêmement fin pour voir
comment les juges fixent ça et le
caractère potentiellement inégalitaire
du point de vue Femme Homme mais je je
je développe pas ce point parce que ce
ce ce serait trop long et puis c'est pas
mes mes travaux mais je je je vous dis
qu'il y a aussi des choses à regarder de
ce
côté-là donc cette ASF complémentaire
elle vise à compléter donc si le juge
euh estime que enfin fixe la pension à
100 € par mois par enfant euh la SF est
aujourd'hui de 187 € elle a été
substantiellement augmentée en octobre
2022 et bien la SF sera versé pour un
montant de 87 €. donc c'est un élément
très important hein parce que c'est un
élément qui vient compléter pour les
familles les plus précaires la pension
minimale ça fixe en fait une pension
minimale par enfant par
mois et là le problème qui se pose est
vraiment le taux de non recours sur
lequel on n pas je pourrais pas vous
dire un chiffre exact de ce non recours
il y a des évaluations je pense
notamment aux travaux de Muriel puchci
et Bertrand Fragonard qui ont fait un
rapport très important que je vous
peut-être vous l'avez vu mais qu'il faut
absolument consulter hein parce qu'il
est extrêmement euh riche et exhaustif
sur toutes les questions que vous vous
posez ici euh et donc voilà ce ce taux
de non recours est relativement est très
probablement important et ça c'est c'est
c'est vraiment une question clé parce
que vous voyez bien qu'on éélève pas un
enfant avec 100 € par mois et encore
moins avec 50 € par mois donc à minima
s'assurer que les familles qui sont
éligibles recours à cette ASF
complémentaire c'est un point qui est
euh qui est vraiment
important à garder en tête et puis enfin
il reste l'ASF dite recouvrable qui est
versé lorsque le parent non gardien ne
verse pas sa pension la pension qu'il
doit verser qui a été fixée par le juge
cette pension elle vient ou elle vient
elle vient compenser cette cette ce ce
ce nonversement en attendant que cette
pension soit recouvrée par les services
de de de de la CAF et donc là dans ce
cas disons que les la solidarité
nationale se substitue aux parents Gard
non gardiens le temps de recouvrer mais
bien évidemment la logique veut que ce
parent nongardien finisse par payer ce
qu'il doit au titre de l'éducation de
son enfant qui est inscrit dans le droit
et donc elle est donc recouvrable de ce
point de vue
euh voilà je
euh alors quels sont les problèmes euh
posés je vais pas trop je voudrais pas
prendre trop de temps et vous laisser la
la possibilité de peut-être peut-être de
poser des questions en espérant pouvoir
y répondre euh le montant de pension
alimentaire fixé c'est pareil encore une
fois je vous dis on n' pas forcément de
remonté d'informations très homogènes
sur ces questions-là il semblerait que
la ces tre moyennes tourne autour de 160
€ euh donc voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est
cet ordre de grandeur il y a évidemment
une grande variance autour de cette
moyenne he parce que les parents lorsque
le parents non gardien a plus de moyens
elle peut être plus importante y compris
que ce que pourrait fixer le barê et
elle peut être beaucoup plus faible
lorsque le parent
nongardien a des moyens faibles ce qu'il
faut aussi bien garder en tête c'est que
cette prise en compte des ressources du
parent non gardien va dans dans la
fixation de la pension alimentaire
évidemment importante mais en fait ça
n'empêche pas que le parent gardien aura
quand même les frais et en l'occurrence
les mèes et Or ont quand même ce cout à
assumer donc c'est elles qui vont avoir
la charge d'assumer ce coup c'est aussi
elles qui font toutes les démarches
administratives auprès des services de
la de de la CAF pour pouvoir percevoir
ces ces ces prestations c'est tout c'est
tout un travail qui est extrêmement
difficile aussi pour ces personne on
sait que c'est pas des moments de vie
euh qui sont faciles et donc c'est c'est
essentiellement sur les femmes que va
peser ce ce ce ce travail là donc ça
peut expliquer aussi des des postures de
non recours il faut aussi engager des
démarches auprès de son conjoint
lorsqu'il ne verse pas la pension ces
démarches elles sont difficiles euh donc
voilà tous ces éléments-l sont à prendre
en compte encore une fois il y a
beaucoup de travaux hein du côté de la
sociologie du droit qui pourrait vous
intéresser pour documenter cette
questionl alors quels sont je vais juste
aller vite sur la question un peu
technique extrêmement technique des
problèmes que pose le recouvrement des
pensions alimentaires et du traitement
dans le système socio-ofiscal d'une part
de la SF d'autre part de la c3e qui est
peut-être le point qui vous intéressait
il y a plusieurs travaux qui ont pointé
des dysfonctionnements alors des travaux
issus du conseil de la famille il y a eu
un gros rapport sur ces questionsl en
2020 euh des travaux que j'ai mené avec
Muriel Puci à
l'OFCE et des travaux ensuite
complémentaires extrêmement riches que
j'ai déjà mentionné qui ont été réalisé
par Bertrand Fragonard et Muriel Puci
qui de façon très exhaustive qui aborde
toutes les questions à la fois de
plafond de montant d'articulation des
différents dispositifs et cetera alors
juste pour être un peu simple euh le
problème qui se pose c'est que la
loocation de soutien familial n'est pas
traitée dans les bases ressources des
prestations sociales de la même façon
que la la pension alimentaire
euh en particulier du coup la pension
alimentaire rentre dans les bases
ressources par exemple pour le calcul de
la prime d'activité et du RSA dans les
deux foyers j'attire votre attention
parce que c'est un point assez important
ce qui veut dire que alors le parent non
gardien lorsqu'il est éligible au RSA
est souvent jugé hors d'état donc ne
paye pas de pension donc de ce côté-là
ça ne joue pas par contre il peut très
bien avoir droit à la prime d'activité
or on va considérer que la pension qu'il
verse elle est toujours dans ses
ressources pour le calcul de la prime
d'activité de la même façon la mère
gardienne qui perçoit cette ce va devoir
la déclarer dans ses bases ressources
autrement dit on compte deux fois ce
revenu dans les bases ressources des
prestations sociales en tout cas RSA et
prime d'activité dans le système fiscal
c'est au moins plus euh j'allais dire
plus cohérent puisque le père non le
père le parent non gardien le plus
souvent le père va déduire de son revenu
imposable la pension alimentaire qu'il
verse à son exconjointe madame va devoir
la déclarer dans son revenu mais
bénéficiera de la demi-part
supplémentaire pour isolement dont je
parlais tout à l'heure le système n'est
probablement pas parfait il y a beaucoup
de de de de questionnement autour de de
de ce système là mais à minima on compte
pas de fois donc voyz a quand même un
peu un double standard entre la façon
dont on traite cette question là pour
les ménages qui sont les plus précaires
et ceux plutôt imposables qui vont être
plutôt plus aisés donc là il y a
certainement une réflexion à avoir sur
sur la façon dont on traite cette
pension alimentaire dans à la fois le
système fiscal d'une part et le système
social donc ça c'est un premier élément
à garder en tête ensuite je vous parlais
pour le parent gardien il peut y avoir
dans certaines situations que nous avons
identifié donc encore une fois les
travaux de Muriel Puci sont extrêmement
importantes ce point de vue là il peut y
avoir des situations dans lesquelles
lorsque le la le parent gardien recouvre
sa pension ça peut conduire à une baisse
de son revenu disponible parce que pour
1 € de pension reçu elle perd plus d'un
€ en prestation sociale que ce soit
allocation logement prime d'activité
lorsqu'elle y est éligible euh et cetera
et cetera donc vous avez en fait euh ce
qu'on appelle un taux marginal effectif
d'imposition qui est très élevé dans
certains cas ça veut pas dire que c'est
vrai tout le temps mais voyez ça c'est
quand même un dysfonctionnement ce à
quoi on s'attend c'est ce que c'est que
c'est à ce que lorsque la pension est
recouvrée il y ait un maintien du niveau
de vie lorsque la pension est fixée au
niveau de la SF et une augmentation
lorsqu'elle y est supérieure alors c'est
pas c'est pas systématique et ça c'est
quand même un un un problème qui qui
mériterait d'être d'être creusé c'est
d'autant plus important qu'on est dans
une situation où à juste titre on ch on
cherche à recouvrer davantage les
pensions alimentaires ce qui est
évidemment louable et c'est ce qui doit
être fait hein c'est au parent le parent
non gardien doit absolument contribuer à
l'éducation de ses enfants mais
néanmoins euh lorsque ça conduit à des
situations où où le le le revenu
disponible de la du parent- gardien
diminue évidemment là ça ça ça pose
problème donc euh cette cette dynamique
du meilleur recouvrement des pensions
doit impérativement s'accompagner d'un
j'allais dire toilettage ou d'une
refonte selon les ambitions du système
socioofiscal de sorte à corriger à
minima ces éléments et si possible à les
améliorer je veux pas trop rentrer dans
le détail je pense que cet exercice nous
ce que ce qui a été eff fait c'est
vraiment de pointer ces
dysfonctionnements par qu type encore
une fois M puli a fait un travail très
important avec une maquette du système
socio-fiscal qui permet de faire des
castypes précis qui permet d'identifier
les situations dans lequell il y a des
dysfonctionnements c'est c'est c'est
donc un point très important maintenant
il y a un exercice de
microsimulation qui doit être fait pour
simuler plusieurs types de réformes
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
notre système sociofiscal est très
complexe il y a une imbrication à la
fois
multiples dans les bases ressources et
donc il il faut aussi juste faire
attention à ne pas tout déstabiliser euh
donc clairement il y a des pistes très
importantes à creuser il faut
certainement plus d'études et le conseil
de la famille l'avait souligné dans son
rapport comme une proposition plus
d'études d'impact pour voir quelle
pourrait être la réforme la plus
structurante mais à minima il y a quand
même des ajustements qui peuvent être
fait qui qui ont été proposés d'ailleurs
par le Conseil de la famille ou par
Muriel BCI et moi dans dans le le le
document que nous avions publié à l'OFCE
par exemple on pourrait imaginer un
abattement de l'ASF un abattement dans
les bases ressources lorsque l'on prend
en compte la pension alimentaire un
abattement du montant de la SF par
exemple c'est une à minima à court terme
c'est des choses qui permettent de
limiter les effets un peu complexes dont
je parlais mais la solution serait quand
même de toiletter de renettoyer enfin de
de reprendre un peu à plat euh ses
prestations sociales et familial et le
système fiscal de sorte à voir un peu
tous les écueils et avoir une vision un
peu globale c'est un gros travail mais
je pense que on peut pas se se passer de
de ce travail- làà si on veut vraiment
avoir un système qui permet de prendre
en compte à la fois comme je disais la
multiplicité des situations et leur
complexité et en même temps soutenir au
mieux les familles et en particulier les
familles qui sont dans les situations
les plus précaires ce qui me semble être
l'urgence aujourd'hui euh un dernier mot
peut-être sur l'accès au logement
puisque vous vous le mentionnerz je
voudrais vous juste vous mentionner un
travail très intéressant qu'ont fait des
collègues de l'OFCE sur l'accès au
logement social qui est issu d'un
rapport qu'ils ont réalisé pour le
Défenseur des droits euh et dans lequel
il montre donc encore une fois la
situation est très complexe dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux même
si les familles monoparentales sont
plutôt prioritaires donc elles ont
plutôt toute chose égal par ailleurs
plutôt un avantage entre guillemets dans
l'accès au logement social comme elles
sont très nombreuses parmi les les
ménages précaires évidemment cet
avantage est assez faible donc là aussi
la question du logement
ou alors je vais reformuler différemment
la question des conditions de vie et de
la situation socio-économique des
familles monoparentales elle est elle
s'inscrit dans de multiples chantiers
évidemment la question de l'accès au
logement en éteint je terminerai par le
marché du travail mais juste un
mot encore une fois nous avions fait un
rapport en 2020 à l'OFCE sur la
situation socio-économique des parents
isolés dans lequel on avait montré qu'il
y avait une fragilité une PR carité plus
importante vis-à-vis du chômage des mers
isolées en particulier donc les les les
les dans les départements dans lesquels
le chômage est très élevé la
participation au marché du travail des
mères isolées est plutôt plus faible
toute chose égal par ailleurs en
comparaison des mères en couple ce qui
veut dire que lorsque le marché du
travail est extrêmement euh dégradé
elle sont les les probablement les il y
a ce qu'on appelle un chômage découragé
c'est-à-dire que elle se elle ne cherche
plus de travail parce que soit les
emplois qui sont proposés ne sont pas
compatibles avec une situation telle que
être parent isolés en matière d'horaire
en matière de temps de trajet en matière
d'organisation de la vie soit parce qu'
il y a tout simplement beaucoup moins
d'emplois qui qui leur sont proposé donc
c'est aussi des choses à creuser parce
que bien évidemment derrière cette
situation socio-économique des mères
isolées il y a la question de l'accès à
l'emploi et et évidemment pour elle
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que pour
d'autres parents voilà je pense que je
je j'ai balayer un petit peu large je
m'en excuse j'espère avoir répondu à
beaucoup de vot vos questions mais je
vous laisse me demander des compléments
si vous le souhaitez écoutez merci
beaucoup je vais donc laisser la parole
maintenant à nos deux
rapporteurs Colomb Brossel merci merci
beaucoup alors en effet vous avez
répondu à beaucoup des questions qu'on
qu'on se posait notamment sur le le
système socio-fiscal et les les
curseurs qui peuvent avoir un impact
lourd j'ai du coup deux questions la
première j'ai bien compris qu'il fallait
qu'on lise l'étude de Madame Pucci et
Monsieur j'ai noté Fragonard voilà
néanmoins les qu types est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire rapidement quels sont
les qu type de famille monoparentales
qui sont les plus impactés par ce
système qui n'est pas totalement ni
clair ni ni égalitaire première première
question et euh la la deuxème
euh vous vous avez pointé dans dans vos
propos et et vraiment je je vous en
remercie la
la le caractère difficile parfois pour
un certain nombre de familles
monoparental de parents non gardiens de
rentrer dans des procédures process sur
le paiement de la pension alimentaire
disant que de fait il y avait un un taux
de non recours
important alors on va interroger
évidemment la les les autres
intervenants aujourd'hui mais de là où
vous êtes et notamment le Haut Conseil
et l'OFCE est-ce que un système de
recouvrement des pensions alimentaires
qui ne passerait pas par la caisse
d'allocation familiale mais qui serait
automatisé en bant par l'administration
fiscale est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui au-delà de l'exemple canadien est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
avoir un impact positif sur ce taux de
de
recouvrement alors je suis en train de
regarder les cas types parce qu'il y en
a beaucoup donc là j'ai j'ai
j'ai sous les
yeux l'effet de la un graphique dans
lequel on montre l'effet de la prise en
compte de la pension alimentaire dans le
calcul des transferts
sociaux avec le cas par exemple d'un
parents gardien qui a deux enfants parce
que voyez c'est compliqué c'est combien
d'enfants c'est l'âge des enfants parce
qu'on ne perçoit pas les mêmes
prestation selon l'âge des enfants donc
là nous avions pris le cas d'un parent
gardien avec deux enfants âgés de 6 et 8
ans qui percevait le montant moyen de la
c3e alors là on avait pris 190 € par
enfant par mois et donc le total des
prestations perçu en fonction du revenu
de cette personne alors attendez
j'essaie de euh voilà des revenus du
travail en pourcentage d'un salaire du
SMIC à temps plein euh et donc
évidemment quand vous prenez au audelà
de de Smic à temps plein vous êtes dans
les zones où il y a des prestations
familiales qui sont perçues mais
évidemment une imposition enfin
progressivement à mesure que les les
revenus augmentent la personne devient
imposable et dans le le début des euh
des dans le tout début de la
distribution des revenus ce qu'on
montrait c'était que il y avait un un
taux comme je disais un taux marginal
effectif d' imposition c'est-à-dire pour
1 € perçu combien on déduit donc pour
quelqu'un qui n'avait pas de ressources
c'était à peu près équivalent mais pour
quelqu'un qui avait 50 % du revenu
pardon du d'un SMIC qui touchait 50 %
d'un SMIC ça faisait un taux marginal
d'imposition de 119 % donc ça c'était
sur les Caspe qu'on avait fait euh donc
pour 1 € perçu on perd 19 centimes de de
prestation et ça allait pour un SMIC à
130 % donc voilà c'est c'est évidemment
tout ça et et il faut regarder voyez
tout ça les c'est tout se cache dans ces
détails là c'est pour ça que c'est
toujours compliqué de donner un Kype et
un chiffre parce que en fait les
situations sont multiples mais
simplement c'est assez clairement
identifié disons que cet
effet cet effet taux marginaux effectifs
d'imposition élevé sur ces tranches de
revenus là pour ce type de configuration
sont anormal sont anormaux en fait c'est
c'est voilà donc voilà après encore une
fois je sais que c'est il y a voilà il y
a beaucoup de travaux donc faut regarder
un peu en détail euh pour voir quel sont
les les cas qui sont les plus les plus
saillants alors je voulais aussi vous
dire que sur l'avantage de la méthode de
katyp c'est qu'elle permet d'identifier
très clairement ce qui se passe dans une
situation extrêmement précise en
revanche elle ne vous donne pas la
représentativité de la personne voilà
donc c'est pour ça que la
microsimulation est un est un outil qui
est indispensable dans l'exercice que
qu'il faudrait engager pour vraiment
proposer une réforme précise parce que
les les modèles de microsimulation
permettent de voir à la fois les effets
redistributifs qu'on n'anticipe pas
nécessairement avec des CYPES la la
masse des personnes qui vont être
concernées par les réformes qu'on
propose le coût aussi qui peut être
aussi un point important donc voilà
c'est c'est il faut vraiment avoir ces
deux ces deux outils pour bien manipuler
notre système socioiscal et sa
complexité sur votre deuxième question
honnêtement je je je je je je ne saurais
pas vous dire je saurais enfin je
pourrais vous dire un avis mais c'est je
p pense que il faut vraiment consulter
des personnes qui ont il y a il y a dans
ce que vous dites des dimensions
relatives au droit et relative à la
sociologie des familles monoparentales
dans leur capacité à à accéder à des
services
différents donc c'est sûr que
l'automaticité forcément c'est un
élément qui va favoriser qui va
favoriser le recours ne serait-ce que le
recours aux prestations publies et et
donc soutenir les les familles
monoparentales il est clair que avoir à
faire des démarches et quelque chose qui
est un frein euh donc ce que je
comprends la sociologie des de de des
travaux en sociologie sur cette question
c'est que il y a clairement des
difficultés à un moment où on se sépare
d'avoir aller faire des démarches
administratives l'argent est aussi
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
sensible dans ces moments-là et qui
prend une dimension très affective des
deux côtés donc là les travaux de cbil
golac et C baessières sont très
éclairants de ce point de vue-là donc
voilà c'est sûr qu'on a plutôt envie de
tourner la page et pas forcément envie
de de de de rentrer dans des démarches
difficiles et encore une fois ce sont ce
sont sou ce sont plus souvent les femmes
qui vont avoir à faire ces démarches en
plus de la
garde la garde principale de des enfants
qui seul forcément implique un
investissement en temps plus important
donc c'est c'est toutes ces questionsl
qui qui sont à prendre en compte mais
c'est sûr que garantir le recours aux
prestations publiques et garantir le
paiement des des pensions dues par le
parent non gardien sont des éléments
absolument euh incontournable de la
question que vous posez
oui merci beaucoup pour votre exposé
alors je reviens avec à ce que vous à
votre dernière phrase garantir le le
paiement des prestations dues est-ce que
un un prélèvement à la source pourrait
être une solution pour éviter justement
cette démarche nécessairement à faire
pour le le parent gardien parfois vous
disiez c'est très compliqué c'est par
souvent euh enfin subi affectivement
parce que c'est c'est des contraintes et
c'est parfois compliqué et c'est sources
de conflit donc est-ce qu'ici en passant
par un un prélèvement la source on
aurait quelque chose de beaucoup plus
carré beaucoup plus légal entre
guillemets sans ça c'est le premier
point et le deuxième point il était la
question de Dominique concernant le le
statut le statut d'une de d'un parent
isolé enfin d'un d'une famille dont la
le parent est isolé pour l'éducation des
enfants est-ce que vous croyez que ça
pourrait changer quelque chose alors
c'est peut-être pas trop dans votre
domaine de compétence mais mais je sais
pas voilà c'était une question sur la
question du statut alors c'est vous avez
raison c'est pas tout à fait dans mon
domaine de compétence non je pense que
dans ce qu'on avait identifié ce qui est
bien
montrer dans à la fois dans les travaux
du au Conseil de la famille et puis dans
les différents travaux qui existent
c'est notamment je l'ai pas mentionné là
mais c'est un point important il y a eu
un un dans la prise en compte par
exemple dans les bases ressources de la
C3 UF ça pose aussi des problèmes au
niveau du soutien au niveau des
collectivités locales je pense notamment
à la tarification sur de la cantine du
périscolaire qui sont des éléments qu'on
ne peut pas quantifier mais qui sont
très importants on les mentionne mais on
peut pas évidemment donc là tout ce dont
j'ai parlé c'était hors ça évidemment
dans le quotidien des parents ce sont
des éléments très importants à prendre
en compte moi ce que je vois dans
l'avantage d'un statut ce serait ça ce
serait un accès direct à certaines
prestations notamment les aides locales
voilà après peut-être qu'il y a des
questions juridiques qui se pose que je
que je ne vois pas donc je ne perçois
pas mais c'est vrai que ça c'est un
point dans le quti iden des mes isolé
c'est un point très important à prendre
en compte et sur lequel on n pas du tout
de vision claire et de on a encore une
fois on ne dispose pas de de
statistiques homogène et de remonter
d'informations qui permettrai de voir
les différences à la fois
territoriales de de ces modes de
tarification qui sont évidemment très
importants et votre première
question à la source ah
ouii alors ça c'est des dispositifs donc
si je me trompe pas c'est ce qui c'est
un peu ce qui est fait dans le système
du Québec qui est très souvent mis en
avant hein c'est que plutôt que de
demander aux parents non gardien de
payer et bien on lui prend directement
ce qu'il doit donc évidemment aller vers
un système comme ça c'est quelque chose
qui euh potentiellement réduit d'abord
tous les les les les coûts
administratifs liés au recouvrement des
pensions donc ça c'est évidemment non
négligeable il me semble que vous allez
auditionner le le directeur de de la
CNAF donc vous pourrez voir avec lui
hein les voilà c'est ce que j'ai vu dans
votre agenda donc je pense qu'il pourra
vous expliquer euh euh l'engagement de
cette institution pour recouvrir ses
pensions qui est extrêmement important
et donc évidemment c'est tout autant de
choses enfin de ressources qu'on
pourrait
utiliser pour par exemple encourager le
recours aux prestations encore une fois
par exemple la SF
complémentaire qui qui très clairement
mériterait d'être beaucoup plus même si
je sais que les CAF ont cette cette
mission aussi d'aller chercher les
personnes qui sont éligibles mais qui ne
réclament pas leur leur droit mais ça
c'est un point effectivement très
important y a-t-il des questions parmi
nos collègues oui Laurence Rossignol
merci juste une précision sûr que j'ai
bien compris ce que nous disait Aline
pvier un instant dans la question de la
base ressources en fait moi j'avis bien
en tête les questions fiscales mais
j'avais pas en tête cette affaire là et
donc ce que vous nous dites c'est que
l'ASF n'est pas prise en compte dans la
base ressources alors que la pension
alimentaire c'est ça alors pas pas dans
les mêmes pas dans les mêmes proportions
en fait c'est encore plus compliqué que
ça parce
que
alors parce que il y a il y a eu des
dans je me 2013 où il y a eu des des
augmentations qui du coup pour pouvoir
garantir qu'elle bénéficie à tout le
monde il y a un certain nombre
d'abattements qui ont pu être faits mais
pas sur l'ensemble je je m'exprime assez
mal du coup en
fait c'est elle est moins prise en
compte que la c3e qui elle est
intégralement dans dans les bases
ressources de fait voilà je pense aussi
que un élément qui est ce que j'essayé
de mentionner he c'est la la double le
double comptage de de la pension dans
les pour les ménages les plus précares
me semble aussi quelque chose pour le
coup qui qui mériterait l'attention de
votre votre travail parce
que alors qu' encore une fois dans le
système fiscal on a au moins quelque
chose qui ne compte pas deux fois une
ressource ici elle est compté dans les
deux
foyers par contre la la c3e par exemple
est compté dans les deux foyers donc le
paère je sais pas si c'est sur à quoi
vous fait RÉR non sur le plan social al
les base ressources du du RSA alors le
RSA encore une fois pour le parent non
gardien ça compte pas parce que il pay
pas pension mais il pourrait être
éligible à la prime d'activité par
exemple et donc lui il va compter il va
conserver dans son revenu dans la la
pension qu'il verse à sa conjointe et
son à son excjointe son n conjointe va
devoir l'intégrer dans sa base
ressources donc c'est compté deux fois
en fait d'un point de vue global on
compte deux fois cette cette pension euh
il y a une proposition de loi qui a été
adoptée à l'Assemblée qui
euh prévoit de ne plus intégrer la c3e
dans le revenu fiscal des maire savoir
qu ce que vous en pensez et ma deuxème
question c'est euh sur la la
déconjugalisation de l'ASF quel est
votre point de vue le point de vue du
hcfea quoi alors qui bon alors sur la
première
question la proposition du conseil de la
famille une des propositions du conseil
de la famille était
de de sortir en fait la pension
alimentaire du système fiscal et de
partager dans ces cas-là c'estàd si
Monsieur la garde dans son revenu
c'estàd ne la déduit pas de son revenu
je dis monsieur pour le par ou et Madame
ne l'intègre si Madame ne l'intègre plus
monsieur va le garder dans son revenu et
dans C cas-là il faut qu'il y a un
partage départ c'est c'est voilà alors
c'était la proposition du conseil de de
la
famille ça veut dire aussi que il faut
probablement donc ce que disait le
conseil de la famille c'était aussi
revenir sur un partage des prestations
sociales et familiales ça ce serait dans
un monde idéal où on saurait exactement
qui contribue à quoi en terme de temps
parce que vraiment j'attire votre
attention qu'il y a pas que des dépenses
physique mais il y a aussi le temps
qu'on consacre pourquoi pas ça permet
aussi au au père non gardien ou au père
qui a une partie de la garde de
s'investir davantage et d'avoir
d'avantage de mais il faut être sûr que
ce soit fait or les travaux de
sociologie montrent que même enfin en
cas de garde alterner ou partager il y a
pas nécessairement un partage
parfaitement égal du temps et de
l'investissement en temps donc je si le
et là voilà je n'ai pas de réponse à
vous donner C il y a une forme de
dissonance entre ce que peut faire le
système socioofiscal en matière de
partage des transferts publics pour les
parents séparés et ce qui va se passer
dans la réalité en matière de partage
effectif des tâches et des coûts on le
sait c'est déjà vrai dans les couples le
partage des tâches est inégalitaire donc
dans les couples séparés il est très
probable que ça le reste mais aller vers
quelque chose qui serait dans un monde
idéal les parents se séparent ils
partagent les tâches on partage à la
fois la charge fiscale et les
prestations sociales qui sont associées
aux enfants bien sûr c'est c'est c'est
ce vers quoi on pourrait aller mais au
aujourd'hui voilà ça c'était la solution
du du du du conseil au Conseil de la
famille qui avait une solution plan B
disons qui était comme je vous le disais
qui est la solution un peu j'allais dire
plus facile à mettre en œuvre qui est de
déduire l'ASF le à la hauteur de laasf
dans la c3e ce qui est pris en compte
alors ça c'est une solution y compris du
côté de la mer lorsqu'elle déclare son
revenu imposable on peut très bien faire
un
abattement plus important de ce qu'elle
doit intégrer dans ses revenus euh h
donc voilà après moi moi il me semble
quand même qu'un point à garder en tête
c'est que
euh l'urgence c'est vraiment les
familles monoparentales précaires même
si le sujet n'est pas seulement celui-là
il y a aussi des parents SIP Paris qui
ne sont pas précaires et je ne dis pas
que c'est pas important mais je dis
quand au regarde de ce que de mon propos
introductif sur la question des taux de
pauvreté ou ce dont on vient de ce dont
on vient t'évoquer sur les bases
ressources et l'accès aux prestations
sociales là il y a quand même une
urgence euh à réfléchir à à ces
dispositifs sur la déconjugalisation de
laasf c'est évidemment un point
important euh parce
que effectivement lorsque la mère isolée
se remet en couple elle perd le droit à
l'ASF alors par contre le parent
nongardien s'il paye une ces tre doit
continuer à la payer ça on est bien
d'accord mais néanmoins voilà on
considère que son nouveau conjoint
participe en partie euh à l'éducation
des enfants
alors déconjugaliser complètement
coûters très cher même si c'est très pas
facile d'évaluer le coût on pourrait à
minima la maintenir pendant une période
c'est ce que proposait le conseil de la
famille la maintenir pendant un an après
la remise en couple pour éviter la perte
immédiate de cette prestation là on
touche du doigt quelque chose qui est
très compliqué je prends juste un tout
petit peu de de hauteur par rapport au
sujet c'est comment notre système
sociofiscal peut prendre en compte les
solidarités comment les solidarités
publiques peuvent s'articuler avec des
solid solidarité privée qui sont
aujourd'hui multiformes complexes c'est
vrai quand on se remet en couple on a un
logement qui on retombe sur cette
histoire d'économie d'échelle mais en
même temps c'est vrai que il y a pas de
raison que le nouveau
conjoint prenne en charge les le coût
des enfants de
son parfois il en a lui-même donc voilà
ça mais je veux juste dire que c'est
c'est il y a quand même cette question
là elle s'inscrit là-dedans quelle place
des solidarités privées dans leur
recomposition dans ces dynamique que
j'ai décrite très grossièrement au début
de mon propos c'est-à-dire voilà les les
gens se mettent en couple se séparent
font famille ont des enfants à nouveau
et cetera comment prendre en compte ces
nouvelles formes de solidarité privée
qui qui peuvent qu'on peut pas
complètement balayer d'un revers de la
main sans et conserver des solidarités
publiques qui permettent aux enfants
d'être élevés dans de bonnes conditions
voilà ça c'est un défi je n'ai pas la
réponse je n'ai pas la réponse à cette
question complexe mais on peut trouver
des solutions et enc encore une fois le
conseil de la famille l'avait suggéré he
enfin l'avait proposé au moins de de
conserver laasf le droit à laasf pendant
une certaine durée après la remise en
couple pour éviser pour éviter cette
perte de de de de ressources juste je
peux madame la Présidente merci euh
juste sur la la déconj enfin sur laasf
la suspension de laasf quand la la mère
plus souvent s met en couple en fait on
a nous les dossiers qu'on voit euh quand
les gens nous nous appellent en dernière
cours c'est plutôt des dossiers de dans
laquelle la caisse de la question famale
demande la restitution d'une ASF perçue
alors que la personne était remise en
couple et les sommes peuvent être
parfois très élevées moi j'ai un dossier
où c'est à 5000 ça se joue à 5000 € 5000
€ c'est beaucoup d'argent pour une mère
monoparentale et
donc dans le la proposition de laisser
un délai en fait ça n'aboutirait qu'à
une chose c'est rédu d'un an le montant
de la la répétition de la rtitution de
l'indu donc je un peu un peu perplexe
moi j'ai quand même tendance à penser
que cette histoire de de de
conjugalisation de laasf repose sur un
postulat c'est que le nouveau conjoint
va
contribuer à l'éducation des enfants
et le raison en parle absurde et vous
l'avez évoqué c'est bah dans ce cas-là
faut supprimer la C TR puisquil a un
nouveau conjoint faut la baisser et
cetera or ça marche pas comme ça donc je
lâche plutôt pas sur la question de la
déconjugalisation de laasf et ça c'est
la la la première chose que je voulais
vous dire et sur vous avez raison de
dire que la question des familles
monoparentales c'est d'abord la préc
c'est d'abord celle des familles
précaires mais il se trouve que si
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup plus des
familles monoparentales c'est parce
qu'il y a des militants c'est parce
qu'il y a des femmes qui sont organisées
qui font entendre la voix des familles
monoparental et qu'impose le sujet dans
le débat public or celles-ci ne sont pas
les plus précaires comme d'habitude
c'est pas les plus précaires qui
s'organisent le plus et donc elles
élaborent enfin elles ont elles
travaillent ensemble mais les moteurs
sont souvent des femmes qui sont un peu
au-dessus de la sont au-dessus de la
précarité et il faut aussi prendre en
compte ces ces réseaux militants et ce
que des propositions apportent à ces
femmes qui militent voyez-vous et on ne
peut pas uniquement traiter la question
de la monoparentalité par sous le biais
de la pauvreté de la grande précarité
les autres aussi sans compter qu'il y a
un troème dont on parle pas mais alors
là c'est pareil je sais pas comment
l'aborder c'est j'ai l'absolue
conviction que dans les milieux plus
favorisé quand les femmes travaillent
elles ne demandent même pas de pension
alimentaire selon une règle assz selon
principe assez simple du moment qu'il
s'en occupe je vais pas rentrer en
conflit sur la pension alimentaire
surtout quand les gens n'étaient pas
mariés et qu'ils ont pas besoin de
passer devant le juge voilà et il y a là
une chez les femmes qui gagnent leur vie
correctement il y a là quelque chose
d'assez lourd qu'il faudra peut-être
quand même dire à défaut de savoir
comment on le traite ça je ne sais pas
c'est de la liberté individuelle et
contractuel
voilà non mais bien sûr ENF je non mon
point était pas de dire que c'est pour
ça je pense qu'il y a une question
générale qui est la répartition des
charges et des ressources au moment de
la séparation et qui touche toutes les
catégorie sociale et il y a pas de
raison de dire
que voilà une femme cadre n'a pas de
enfin elle a les mêmes droits elle a
tout auutant le droit de réclamer et son
son conjoint doit doit participer à
l'entretien à l'éducation des enfants
alors quand même ce qu'on sait alors ce
que je voulais juste dire d'abord c'est
que la raison pour laquelle je me suis
plus focalisé là-dessus c'est parce
qu'on parle quand même de prestations
sociales que c'est quand même du coup
pour le coup il sont quand même là
beaucoup plus pour soutenir les les
ménages les plus précaires euh ce qui
n'épuise pas l'entièreté du sujet mais
il y a d'abord quelques dispositions qui
ont été pris je pense notamment à aux
questions de fraude fiscal qui récemment
on é ont été tranché pour les excjoint
qui se qui se trouvait pouvoir être
toujours solidaire de dett fiscal ah oui
Ahou VO voilà bon voilà
ok non mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup ces questions là sont sont sont
aussi importantes mais là comme comme on
était plutôt sur quelque chose relatif
au voilà mais je je suis je suis
d'accord je voulais juste dire aussi que
l'urgence c'était aussi de soutenir ses
ménages et ses
enfants un point sur la conjugalisation
je veux il y a il y a quand même des
questions de cûpt qu'on peut pas évacuer
d'un revers de la main donc on peut se
dire dans un monde idéal il serait
évidemment très souhaitable d'avoir une
ASF
déconjugalisé après les ressources ne
sont pas infinies il faut savoir où
est-ce qu'on veut les placer donc se
dire qu'on garde un délai évidemment ça
ne voilà ça n'empêchera pas des
situations tel que celle que vous
décrivez mais on garde un délai de
maintien de la SF et et on met cet
effort en matière de ressources sur des
points qui peuvent nous sembler plus
importants donc je pense par exemp le
recouvrement de la SF complémentaire est
un point vraiment important de à
comprendre pourquoi ces familles ne
demande pas ce complément de de de
pension alimentaire euh cette cette
cette histoire de aussi de de de
d'incohérence du système socio-fiscal
qui fait perdre des droits en allocation
logement euh en prime d'activité en RSA
bah c'est des éléments qui vont avoir un
coût pour les finances publiques he
forcément parce que ça veut dire qu'on
va devoir payer et c'est bien normal ces
prestations à hauteur de ce que de ce ce
qu'elles doivent être donc voilà je
pense qu'il faut un peu voir où est-ce
qu'on veut placer nos ressources et ça
ça ça ça me semble être voà des
arbitrages à faire j'ai justement une
question sur le sujet
qui parce que je comprends effectivement
le principe de laasf c'est pour venir
compléter une pension alimentaire
insuffisante pour la prise en charge de
l'enfant et du coup on peut comprendre
que puisque que c'est pour compléter une
pension alimentaire que si la pension
alimentaire était au même niveau elle
resterait au même niveau même si la
femme se remet en couple donc il serait
pas illogique que elle reste également
au même
niveau dans le cadre de l'ASF par contre
comment est calculé laasf et est-ce que
les conditions à la fois de ressources
mais de vie euh de la personne qui
l'aperçoit sont prises en compte parce
que ça pourrait être simplement un un
recalcul en disant bah dor avant au lieu
de payer 100 % d'un loyer vous n'en
payez plus que 50 % et donc on recalcule
la SF par rapport à ça
puisqueeffectivement c'est une
solidarité nationale qui vient compléter
une défaillance de l'un des deux parents
mais qu'on puisse la calculer au plus
juste c'estd à la fois en réfléchissant
aux finances qu'on doit sortir mais en
même temps à la justesse de
l'accompagnement qu'on est censé
fournir je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris
V question par le principe c'est est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on prend en compte les
vrais coûts que la femme majoritairement
est censée porter donc y compris le coût
du logement pour le calcul de la SF
complémentaire monsieur ne donne que 100
€ de pension alimentaire on sait que
c'est insuffisant d'autant que Madame
doit payer un loyer important par
exemple où est-ce que c'est c'est 18
c'est pas du tout calculé par rapport
aux ressours non mais non non la SF elle
est elle est à 187 € 2 centimes point
point donc si Monsieur paye 100 € madame
reçoit 87, 24 centimes de
complémentairire pas s conditionour non
d'accord oui par fait effectivement si
on la mettait sous condition de
ressources d'une façon ou d'une autre on
se dirait bah le fait de se remettre en
couple ça permet ou pas d'ailleurs de se
dire que le loyer étant moins cher bah
les conditions sont plus les même et
donc on recalcule la SF c'était plus
dans ce sens-là puisque au lieu d'être
du tout tout rien quoi non non c'est pas
le principe est pas de tenir compte de
la situation spécifique du parent
gardien c'est comme un c'est un minimum
de pension comme un minimum comme le RSA
mais sauf que c'est pour les pensions
donc on considère qu'on ne peut pas un
enfant ne peut pas vivre avec moins de
187 € par mois et d'où d'où l'enjeu du
non recourant parce que ça veut dire
queil y a des familles qui disposent de
moins de pension que et qui ne demande
pas ce complément alors ma de de
question c'est sur le calcul des
pensions alimentaires vous nous avez dit
qu'il y avait des études qui étaient
faites sur le sujet c'est aussi de
Muriel Puci et Monsieur Fragonard non
c'est de qui c é c'est il y a notamment
un ouvrage collectif par qu'il y a une
grosse recherche de sociologue alors
Émilie bilan curgier hlen Stein Metz
Sybil golac je crois qu'il y a un
ouvrage collectif qui est dirigé par
sibyil golac elles ont utilisé 10 ans de
de jugement du juge aux affaires
familiales donc donc elles ont une base
donc elles ont pu faire des statistiques
et puis aussi une analyse évidemment
sociologique des des différents cas pour
mieux comprendre la façon dont les juges
fixe la pension donc je veux pas parler
pour elle moi j'ai j'ai vu leurs travaux
mais c'est extrêmement riche de ce point
de vue-là donc là on se situerait non
plus du côté du système socioofiscal
mais du côté de l'institution judiciaire
la façon dont c'est fixé moi ma enfin ce
que je comprends de leurs travaux c'est
que bah d'abord il y a une prise en
compte très enfin il y a une prise en
compte de la capacité du parent
nongardien à payer la la CEE mais assez
peu de prise en compte de voilà
certainement en se disant bah il y a la
SF de toute façon Infiné donc voyez et
ça je pense que en en regardant leurs
travaux vous vous pourrez avoir une
vision plus claire des enjeux notamment
en matière d'inégalité femmes homm dans
la fixation des pensions euh et puis
elles ont fait un travail un peu
territorial pour regarder ce qui se
passait dans différentes zones donc
c'est un travail très riche je pourrais
vous donner la la référence plaî oui oui
s'il vous plaît puisque nous recevons le
garde des saau la semaine prochaine nous
pourrons lui poser une question utile
sur le sujet oui
oui y a-t-il d'autres
questions non et ben écoutez on est
pilepoil dans les temps merci beaucoup
merci à vous j'espère vous avoir aidé
dans vos travaux et je
vous des références exactes des travaux
que j'ai mentionnés qui vous permettront
d'aller un peu plus en profondeurlié pas
assez précis sur certains points donc
euh non non mais merci beaucoup en
tout